hey youtubers it's Charlie this is going
to be my guardians of the galaxy trailer
QA I've also got some spider-man
homecoming trailer news I saw an image
that said that the trailer was supposed
to drop during agents of Shield's winter
finale this week that's on Tuesday so
just be sure to subscribe to get that
video make sure you turn alerts on so
that you don't miss anything they just
got done showing off footage of Brazil
comic-con so it would make sense that if
they were going to drop the trailer with
Star Wars rogue one that they would get
ready to drop it online Q&A though here
we go first question much works asks i
love how comic book accurate mantis
looks and acts the minor difference that
they made is just in her skin color in a
slight tweak to her origin story the
thing about mantis in the comics is that
there's been a bunch of different
versions of the character there was even
a version of her that went to DC Comics
for a little while way way back but the
most recent version the one that we all
talk about when we look at mantus here
the green-skinned one with the antenna
she was a Kree experiment that debuted
during an I elation conquest that was
the storyline that formed the Guardians
like that was the first time the current
version of the team came together she is
an empath like we see with that funny
clip at the annual attracts laughing do
me next do me next the best example I
can think of that is deanna troi and her
mother from Star Trek The Next
Generation their empaths they can sense
your emotion so they can sense when
you're feeling sad or happy or anything
they use it for comedy in the trailer
but later in the comics star-lord
actually used it to his advantage like
used to hypnotize other members of the
team to join up so James Gunn just
explained to the change in her
appearance like the change in her skin
is just like the way they changed Drax
and Gamora like they wanted them to all
feel like very different characters so
they just changed the coloring so that's
why mantis is white and not green like
she is in the comics next question
killzone asks what if Nova were there
because he's part of the Guardians in
the ultimate spider-man so I think the
reason the James Gunn said he didn't
want to put Nova in is just because he's
not a huge fan of the character he
doesn't hate him but he just wanted
Peter quill to feel like he was alone in
the galaxy there was one of the big
things about the first movie is that
like they were all a bunch of people
without a family then they became a
family through the course of the film so
that's why they all needed to feel like
outsiders and I think they also wanted
to try and avoid any green lantern
looking stuff like that's why they
changed captain Marvel's backstory or
they will change captain Marvel's
backstory whenever they do her movie
just because the comic book version of
the story reads a lot like how Green
Lantern got his powers next question
fuzzy bear asks I don't know why Groot
hasn't learned how to speak yet besides
saying I am Groot well it's just part of
like the comedy of the character is that
he only can speak his name so he just
says I am Groot we are just variations
of that a lot of you have asked me to do
a group video so I'll totally do like a
full bonus video on Kreutz origin story
in where he's from but his race is flora
Colossus he's from Planet X the reason
why he is so alone is because he felt
like an outsider amongst his own people
they call him saplings and he defended
another mammal and ended up killing
another member of his race so he was
exiled that set him on the path to
meeting rocket raccoon in the other
Guardians they didn't really address it
in the trailer but we see them walking
around on that planet with a bunch of
trees around Groot is able to control
other plants so we might get to see him
use his powers in a way that we haven't
seen before next question a lot of baby
grew questions why does grood have teeth
does he ever eat anything well you know
he mostly just drinks water like you
know plants would drink but the thing is
I think they put teeth on him just so
that they wouldn't freak little kids out
like it would look weird if it was just
like an open hole they wanted him to
feel like a tiny person so that you know
they paid extra attention to his facial
features otherwise he'd be like a little
coconut with legs running around for a
couple hours next question Andrew asks I
thought Jason of spartax was his father
and Captain Victoria was his half-sister
so the reason James gonna explain this
is because he also wanted Peter quill to
feel like a loner in the galaxy I think
he was also not a huge fan of the JSON
of spartax and the spar toy Empire so
even though he wanted Peter quill to
feel like this prince in the galaxy from
this grand heritage he wanted to use ego
the Living Planet just so that everybody
would feel that much more lonely next
question lorenzo asks i'm just hoping
Adam warlock shows up you and everybody
else like ever since we
that cocoon the thing about Adam warlock
is that he's such a big deal in the
Infinity Gauntlet storyline in the
comics but Marvel has taken things in
such a different direction that it
sounds like we're not going to see him
during infinity war because you'd have
to set his character up you'd have to
explain why it's important what the
relationships are and they already have
so many characters so I think if we see
Adam warlock in the movies we'll only
see him in the Guardians movies and
it'll be at easter egg level James
Gunn's been back and forth about whether
or not he's gonna do another Guardians
film after this but I do think that
he'll do it he says he has an idea for
it but it might not happen until phase
four or even phase five so it's not like
they would roll right into production of
that next question Gabriel asks
Guardians three should have iron man in
it at least if James Gunn is not
directing you say just to keep it
interesting I don't think that Marvel
would want to do a guardians movie
without James Gunn so I don't think we
have to worry too much about that that
is like the horror story where like the
really awesome director that makes
something blow up and turns into this
beautiful thing goes away and then it
all just goes to I don't think that
Marvel would want that even though
Guardians is a really big popular
franchise and they want to make more
Guardians films I think they would just
wait until James Gunn's ready to make
another one even if it takes a long time
next question Jordan asks i wonder if
Groot will slowly get bigger and bigger
through the movie but I think the thing
is is that he'll stay tiny for like you
know really tiny for most of the film
and then towards the end there might be
some big moment where he grows up a lot
of it has to do with him wanting to grow
up so the way James Gunn's talked about
this version of Groot is that he's
really rambunctious very rebellious but
it doesn't seem like he's in a rush to
grow up so there will probably be some
moment in the film like where he
sacrificed himself in the first film
where he finally decides these people
need me to do something that I could
only do if I were an adult so I'd be
very surprised if he doesn't grow up
during the film but if you could imagine
infinity war with the Guardians
crossover in Robert Downey jr. trying to
deal with the tiny baby crude they might
try to keep him small for that next
question Dante elite asks why can't all
Marvel movies look this colorful and
vibrant the color grading on most Marvel
film
is so bland and muddy this looks amazing
so the thing about that there's a lot of
criticisms about the way marvel shoots
its films but it has to do with like the
types of cameras they use James Gunn use
something very different this time even
if you're not a camera geek like this is
like the brand new state-of-the-art red
weapon 8k camera this is one of the best
cameras that money can buy right now
like they just started shipping them to
everyone else they shot guardians last
year so a number of filmmakers including
James Gunn were given special versions
of these cameras to try out before they
were available to the public so without
getting into colorescience and like the
mechanics of the actual cameras is
actually pretty fascinating they're
basically just much better than the
cameras that Marvel has been using on
its movies next question Andrew asks I
have to wait five months for this so the
thing is is there's actually a bunch of
other comic book movies dropping before
guardians there's a whole bunch of stuff
happening in the beginning of the year
Lego Batman is actually like one of the
first big comic book movies coming out
that's in February like the beginning of
februari you may have seen the trailer
for it if you saw a movie in the
theaters in the last week or two
Wolverine 3 the Logan movie is right
after that at the beginning of march
then guardians of the galaxy is right at
the beginning of May then Wonder Woman
is right after that so there's actually
a lot of stuff happening at the
beginning of the year so it'll go by a
lot quicker than you think it would next
question rap asks is nebula gonna join
the Guardians if she is didn't she died
last time oh no she didn't die she just
lost a couple limbs and then barely got
away but I wouldn't say that she's going
to become a member of the Guardians but
she is supposed to travel with them for
a brief period family is an important
idea in the film Gomorrah and nebula are
sisters they're both daughters of Thanos
so they're gonna have some fun playing
with that in the film but I think the
idea is that she's less straight up evil
than she was in the first film like
imagine the relationship between thor
and loki loki is kind of a villain but
not always it's a bit of a gray areas
kind of ambiguous sometimes so I'm
expecting the same treatment from nebula
and Gomorrah next question and Simon
asks so as Vin Diesel's still playing
gruene yeah he still did the voice but
obviously they modulated it so that it
sounds like it's coming out of a really
tiny person you probably could have
hired any kind of voice actor to do a
group
face but I think the idea is that if he
might grow big in the film he would need
to have that Vin Diesel Groot voice so
that's probably why they brought him
back but but he essentially spoke all
the lines that he needed to speak and
then they changed the voice to make it
sound like it was coming out of that
teeny tiny little mouth next question
Danny asks who is Wonder Man so assume
you're talking about Nathan Fillion so
that you know the character he's playing
in the movie seems just like a normal
actor but wonder man in the comics is
actually this really weird story he's
kind of this big Avenger that they can't
really use anymore because of IP rights
the biggest story in the comics most
people remember about Wonder Man is that
they used his brain waves and his
personality matrix to revive vision so
he got his powers in this chemical
accident with Baron Zemo but he's
effectively about as strong as Thor in
way back during Stanley era Marvel there
was this big copyright fight with DC
Comics because of the Wonder Woman
character so Stanley just agreed to
never use Wonder Man again so Wonder Man
still exists in the Marvel Universe just
don't expect to see him a whole lot
thank you everybody for so many
questions he's always a ton of fun to do
I'll start doing more q and A's I will
do a spider-man trailer QA whenever that
drops this week so leave all your
questions you know say congratulations
to this giveaway winner roisin rue you
win a thirty dollar comiXology gift card
there will be a new round of the
spider-man give away the next time I
post a marble video I'll just remind
everyone when I post that but there
should be Game of Thrones later today
then walking dead tonight westworld I'll
just update people on the schedule as I
post new videos while you guys wait for
that to post you can click here to
rewatch the Guardians trailer and you
can click here for my breakdown of that
spider-man homecoming footage they
showed off a couple days ago thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you